[Music]
all right so there's a man in thailand
he's a navy sergeant he has been jailed
after video footage that allegedly
showed him training forcing training
marines to drink semen god what is up
with drinks
why do people do this so why force
because i don't think they want to do it
themselves
just find the ones that do how do they
get that they're out there out there
dude how did they get the calm joe asks
me did they jack their own selves off
this is what this is this is why i hate
that's what a prisoner of wars are for
right
that's why you always have to do you're
just jacking off every poww for their
[ __ ] they're like oh this is a nightmare
it has all the the the the up and comers
it depends if you give us secret
information it depends if you want
conflict-free [ __ ] yeah
that's important
no hormone
organically raised gmo non-gmo okay i'll
take that yeah they enjoy it the first
time but that if they keep checking it
off after they come that's how you
torture people right
have you tried doing that that's the
torture method keep jacking off
yeah keeps getting stroking it after you
come you're like okay i'll say anything
don't do anything like just stop you
know because things like [ __ ] yeah
that's when pleasure becomes pain yeah
so that's how you get information you
give them pleasure first and then you
keep going
all right how many people have tasted
their own [ __ ]
on purpose are you are you telling us to
raise our hands or is that you
participating no you've got to raise
your hands you got to raise yourself in
directly
indirectly no no it's all dirty no but
have you tasted your own [ __ ] before just
put your hand up inside of a [ __ ] whoa
there it is
damn it you guys aren't going to put
your hands i was going to put my phone
solid there i said solidarity okay why
why'd you teach your own come forward
did you do it like this it was like oh
is that how you think
is that how you got your brown belt so i
got a couple belts
white through brown my man
blue
purple yellow orange brown uh sensei
said the taste you're calm you get
another belt
you went to a [ __ ] dojo dude
no i never tasted my own [ __ ]
did you taste your own [ __ ]
i mean in this in the similar fashion
like joe is in the heat of the moment
did a girl
suck you off and then pretend that she
swallowed it and spit it in your mouth
oh she did the no that was you see the
jurassic park you know how like every
chef she needs to taste their own
cooking yeah you know so before you you
know give it to somebody do it
ah pineapple yeah are you saying you've
done this sir
uh maybe
is good for the people experiencing it
right absolutely i'm going to be the
uncle roger of porn critiques
oh oh yeah what the hell that's not a
good [ __ ] shot man but it's always going
to be critiquing cream pies
one of my favorite genres
so this navy instructor
was having them drink cement that was
mixed oddly with fish sauce oh
mommy you gotta do mommy in there right
yes hey that's not bad
do you think those work together oh it's
like an oyster shot now it is like a
oyster anything works with fish sauce
[Laughter]
they're navy and they're drinking sea
man hey no i didn't get it so this was
just for a puns world post yeah that's
it video's over video's over turn it off
that's a reel right there navy may drink
sea man with fish sauce
i know is this a vietnamese navy car
yeah oh it's a thai navy they're like
fish sauce so this was a hazing ritual
or was it yeah oh yep they're so tough
it builds characters see they need to
tell us where the source comes from i
still need to know did they come in
their own [ __ ] oyster shooters yeah
if it's like they have to drink their
own cup as like a hazing thing that's
also a little bit like damn that's
amazing but if it's like some somebody
else has come it's like that's what
we gotta fight yeah because someone
else's come as sexual harassment right
but if it's your own income it's just
hazing maybe self-harassment yes yeah
you know
i'm just guessing that it was not their
own comp like why imagine being in the
courthouse when you're trying to it's
like who's comes to drink this is like
my own
that's like funnier right it's in
thailand right they probably thought
they were all women
okay that's it why do you think what do
you think it's not their own thumb why
do i think that yeah it's just a real
guess you know because that means
someone can come that much four to four
cups full that's a lot
give it some time i'm just thinking that
you know the
whoever is watching this go down they
don't necessarily know that they're
drinking calm but they had to find out
whereas everybody would know they're
drinking calm if they're all jerking
themselves off into a cup and then
[ __ ] adding fish
it's hazer [ __ ] you think hazers were
jacking off and be like you want some
muay thai calm [ __ ] and then they
[ __ ] came into a [ __ ] cup and
they're like ha take it and they're like
i don't want to sir muay thai comes you
think they got the idea from van wilder
they're like i came to protect thailand
yeah because that's on some frat [ __ ]
right there making dudes drink your [ __ ]
but that was that was a dog remember
them van walder i don't remember that
where they made a dog come yeah and van
wilder they uh they jack off the dude's
dog and put it in hot dogs and give it
to the frat and then everybody's [ __ ]
eating these hot dogs like come all over
them or whatever like cream puffs and
they're like yeah i gotta re-watch this
movie
what if we're being culturally
insensitive about it because you know in
like certain south east asian countries
like vietnam right guys hold hands
and it's best friends so that's like one
level up from that so yeah maybe a
drinking [ __ ] is kind of like like bffs
or whatever holy hands drinking coffee
it's like back in the day when you would
like [ __ ] cut your hand and shake it
with a blood brother
that's what it means
what's really funny is if this was a
fear factor episode all those people
will be freaked out about the fish sauce
part
it smells smelly
like oh no that's asian i don't want to
drink that
it's disgusting i like it i'll take it
apart i like that
yeah it's like it's like i had a i went
with this woman once and then uh she we
went to get dim sum right and then she
got freaked out by chicken feet and i
said you just ate my ass last night
you freaked out my chicken feet
what what's your logic here
delicious too
white women man they'll eat ass when
they won't touch to eat human ass but
they won't touch chicken feet
i didn't know until him i didn't know
how much white women loved eating that
that's wonderful i'm just adding to cart
all the tickets from your next tour
we gotta see this dude holy [ __ ]
i don't do that bit anymore my son gets
too dirty something oh man i'm gonna be
in the crowd going do the chicken feet
ass eating jokes
poor ass eating
boy where are those fans ass eating is
kind of hack now in the stand-up world
everybody has it right it's a little bit
happy i liked it when it was like real
see this is what i'm saying it's so
normalized it's good enough for jk news
it's like funnier socially than it is
like stage yeah everybody has an ass
eating yourself are you into that though
actually yeah really i told you steve
it's the next blow job
you guys are so [ __ ] outdated you
boomers how did you know that you know
you got two people in you know one focus
on the ass one on the dick
a third serving the chicken feet yeah
that's when it gets really
heaven for me
[Laughter]
call me sam woo
take that chicken foot put in my ass
chicken feet and hookers that's the dim
sum and oh
that's pretty good dim sum is good for
any situation that's true if you if you
eat my ass i remember the entire phone i
will marry you
ladies take no key to my heart
your heart
dtf and then dtf
wow
you know how they got the naked lady
with the sushi the chinese version is
nikki lady with a dim sum yeah get the
[ __ ] different kind of steamboat it's
too hot
because you have to open up the things
and like look oh okay that's chicken
feet oh yeah if you make like asian
hooters that's that dude that's a
business model right there right it
sounds like a lost asian
like a bird a lot of burns uh so
unfortunately there's probably there's
definitely a history of hazing rituals
especially in apparently in
thailand's armed services there was a
2017 case that saw a 19 year old army
recruit die of sudden heart failure his
body showed signs of severe physical
abuse and his family found many of his
organs were missing when they collected
his body oh missing organs what kind of
hazing is that were they selling as
organs but it's a it's a joke though
it's a prank yeah it's just a bit you're
broke right loosen up guys
okay
pc culture gone mad yeah dude don't
cancel us now okay
that's the joke there was also a uh an
investigation into a widespread pattern
of harassment beatings and sexual abuse
against thai military conscripts it's
like the people at the bottom right um
across 26 interviews with former and
serving conscripted soldiers and
commanders including officers
investigators found that reports of
sexual abuse and ritual humiliation were
rampant can't you just replace thailand
with every other country's military and
same [ __ ] same [ __ ] yeah i don't know if
i've ever seen anybody with missing
organs
that's the next level though that is one
that's taking the joke to the next level
took your spleen bro yeah that's an
advanced humor that's what i'm saying
that sounds like something mr beast
would do
[Laughter]
10 youtubers 10 kids
last one who lose cuts out their kidney
wins 10 million
what's the game i just like the idea of
that being a prank like if you woke up
one day and we're all just like
snickering and we're just like hey nick
how many kitties do you got we're all
holding it here like hey look at this oh
no oh my god you guys have my [ __ ]
open oh you got this all good oh [ __ ]
yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god i didn't even see it coming
hey the boys got my kidney again
several organs
or dude you're hooked up to something
and you have to hold on you have to hold
on to a car
and your [ __ ] kidney is hooked up to
the tail of the car
and it's like you can't let go
oh that's some [ __ ] that is the
darkest version of this yeah that's a mr
beats video that's a mr
yeah we made it sound so [ __ ] up we're
trying to enjoy our time here man
i thought i was just playing along with
all the guys all the fellows
pushing the envelope right he just
bummed all of us out
you